so we've got a bunch of charts that
we're going to run through here uh let's
start first with the major central banks
total assets as they continue to rise uh
and help us understand just kind of
contextually like why is this chart
important and what does it really tell
you as you uh look at it
yeah so i mean there's there's a couple
of things like one we have this this new
technology right we have bitcoin and and
so many people are trying to figure this
out and and there's a lot of noise in
like the so-called you know crypto space
right we
all know this but but really i think
what's happening and what's forcing
people to adopt this technology this
monetary technology is we're kind of at
the end of this long-term debt cycle and
most people don't really um understand
this especially if they're you know not
studying macroeconomics or you know have
a have a like uh in-depth you know
history of of monetary assets and and
debt cycles right um but you know
starting in in 08 and in 2020 um we kind
of hit the zero lower bound um and so
central banks kind of ran out of their
their you know main option the firepower
which is interest rate policy and so
you know what they went to is
quantitative easing it's essentially
just stuffing a bunch of cash in in the
bond market or really i mean simplify it
as printing money right um but it's
really just just lowering the discount
rate of of uh or the cost of capital
everywhere on the planet and so these
are all you know the global major
central banks and what this is just
showing is that they're they're trying
to keep the system glued together um but
it's it's you know it's it's cracking
it's tracking up the seams and so um
this is you know actively forcing people
into bitcoin or to seek uh shelter
elsewhere
and so when we look at the total assets
obviously every major central bank just
absolutely took off in 2020 uh for
obvious reasons but also in the united
states we've got this debt chart that
shows a very similar uh type of growth
there at the end in 2020 so explain
what's going on here
yeah so this is is looking at um just
like total debt to gdp um non-financial
financial um and and right now total
debt to gdp is at 400 percent and so uh
my good buddy greg foss um he was on
your show he likes to always talk about
how it's a it's a mathematical certainty
that that fiat will debase because of
basically this chart uh with that the
gdp at 400 percent um given that all
debt has to be repaid plus interest um
unless the economy is growing at 12 15
a year in real terms then then we're in
a debt spiral and there's really no way
out
unless it's default which is politically
not feasible or to basically debase the
currency and so that's what that's you
know that's the game we're playing and
really a lot of people get you know get
upset with the puppets of the game but
it's it's more systematic than that it's
not about trump or biden or powell or
whoever you you want to you know call
shots at and i get it i do it too
sometimes um but it's really it's
systematic um we're in a debt spiral and
and mathematically there's no way out of
this
except to continue printing and um
attempting to kick the can down the road
but more and more people are waking up
and saying i don't want to play this
game yeah i think that's a great way to
describe it uh we've got a chart here of
the real 10-year treasury bond yield
describe uh what's going on with the
10-year yield but also what the
relationship between the 10-year yield
and inflation is
yeah so um
the fed or like the government's way of
measuring inflation i believe is kind of
flawed and i think most people that are
paying attention do as well um but just
for the sake of the argument we'll use
it um it's you know there's pc or cpi
but it's basically just consumer price
inflation um and we're indexing that
against what a you know a treasury bond
could get you what a lot of people in
financial markets you know they use as
their risk-free rate um then what you're
looking at is essentially in this chart
when you break that zero lower bound the
cost of capital is negative right so
when you're evaluating stocks real
estate um any any asset um
when the cost of capital is negative how
what's the fair value and the answer is
uh it doesn't compute it breaks um so if
you're holding a bond or if you're
sitting on a you know 60 40 portfolio if
you're you know in your pension or your
your 401k you're you're losing uh in
real terms and even if nominally you're
you're making out okay um you're
basically getting pillaged if you're if
you're holding bonds or a lot of these
financial assets because the cost of
capital is so distorted and that's
because it's a it's a centrally planned
market and so
i think these are like the the broad
macro trends here um and this is why you
know i think bitcoin would be important
regardless um and you know satoshi
literally uh released bitcoin because of
these problems i think he chose to
release bitcoin kind of strategically uh
but
um this is why bitcoin is especially so
important what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]